so I'm sitting here with the founding
CTO of Udacity Mike Mike how did you
come to the decision in Udacity because
Udacity is running their courses on App
Engine in fact what this course is all
about how did you come to the decision
of using App Engine the very first web
site we built was built for AI class was
a single course and it was built on a
bunch of VPS servers and we had
underestimated the interest that we were
going to get which was awesome but we
ended up with two orders of magnitude
more users than we expected and I was a
relatively novice web developer and so
we hit every single problem you can hit
in terms of scaling up the
infrastructure to meet the demand and so
the entire 14 weeks of the course we
were just playing catch-up the whole
time fixing problems and adding more
bandwidth and adding more machines and
memory and coming out of that we were
looking at launching a bunch more
courses and we were really uncertain
about how much traffic we'd be getting
we'd seen a lot of peaks and so one of
the engineers were a very small team and
one of the engineers had some experience
using App Engine and it sounded like a
really great solution to the problem of
uncertain amount of load and took all of
that headache because we were spending
about half of our engineering hours
doing sysadmin and DevOps work just
trying to keep stuff running and when
you've got a small team and you want to
focus on getting new features out you
want to focus on really working on what
you're good at
then it's wonderful to have a platform
which kind of cushions you for the
spikes and the loads and pushes you in
the right direction
that's fascinating that's exactly what
we're trying to teach in this course
what would be your key messages to the
students of this course what would you
tell them now so I think the advice I
give to the students is it's it's
important to remember their trade-offs
with any framework or platform you use
and one of the things after using App
Engine for a couple years we found is it
seemed like there was a lot more work at
times just to get started to get
something simple up and
but what we found with time is that it
pushes you in the right direction it
pushes you to the best design practices
for building a scalable application so
maybe if you're trying to build
something which will serve 200 people
you could do it quite a bit faster if
you're just running it on a single
machine but the second you get up to
2,000 or 20,000 or 200,000 users it's
made you make some decisions which will
really put you in a better place and
that is that's it I think the most
absolutely valuable thing that it
provides that's great thank you so much
Mike for taking this time I'm sure that
the student will find this valuable
thanks and glad I can help and I really
hope that after taking this course
students have a little bit of an easier
time than we did at the beginning